hello rejects coming at you today I'm
Greg now I'm John we're gonna watch the
trailer for what I'm assuming is gonna
be a 21 Jump Street like movie they wash
sided Bay one Baywatch I didn't watch
the show you're gonna have to watch all
78 season all the movie comes Baywatch
is a classic Hasselhoff Anderson now we
got the Rock and Efron same same thing
yeah enough prep taught our team is the
elite of the elite for the heart so at
this very Beach we protect when other
people don't want to protect what's all
and beyond
[Music]
nice one me you can have me some other
time we're staring into the abyss here
City Council's already cut our funding
brought to us restore the baywatch
planned a job you ready for duty you
just look at my boobs I usually look at
my face
I'm trying and it's so close to your
boobs this is a guy yes a good PR
opportunity for us sure is reckless two
gold medals I mean gold medals do you
have probably zero we got a dead body on
our Beach that's not our job
my gut says there's a bad [ __ ] going on
over there get my ball say we need to
check it out my ball say she's thinking
he's right
what are your ball sound like
three-year-old wise
welcome to Baywatch
crazy
- choice reading slow
you see you too
oh boy you turned the canals into the
damn x-games
yeah that's cuz we were in lifeguard
pursuits there's no such thing as
lifeguard pursuit how do I explain this
so that you people understand you people
you people oh you don't get to say that
you're just 10 Ron oh come on brother
21 Jump Street before Baywatch it
exactly would that agents that I'm
making it all about a huge cast it's
about this buddy pairing and like in
patrol working together unlikely
partners Zac Efron looks like he's doing
a lot of role the role that he's done
and a lot of things especially like
neighbors and stuff I still like
watching Zac Efron I think Zac Efron is
so [ __ ] funny and I think him and the
rock are gonna have great chemistry
together
yeah seems like I mean like it this
looks like a lot of fun like it looks
exactly like what you said is Baywatch
but with the 21 Jump Street sort of like
reproter yeah we get the the Baywatch
program go anything let's ramp up the
action but also be very self-aware with
our comedy I heard I heard David
Hasselhoff is making an appearance I
switch I cause it is so excited for 100%
sure of ham Anderson makes an appearance
I'm sure there's been some announcement
of that that she will it looks crazy and
it looks like fun and it looks like
Baywatch it looks like it'd be a lot of
people in bikinis and there's gonna be a
lot of you know jokes and [ __ ] yeah this
isn't like a reboot that upsets me by
any means at all cuz babe watch Baywatch
is always cheesy and always corny and
it's like Baywatch for the modern day
yeah like amped up like a music video
that comedy is even more apparent and
you know you got the rock in there it
feels like like the crazy-ass fires and
explosions on the beaches
it's like silly as [ __ ] but it looks
like a really really fun time only think
it's missing this Kevin Hart I think
it'd be great if they cross this over
one day we'd set 21 jump straight in men
in black
21 Jump Street and Baywatch you could
totally say Jonah Hill and Channing
Tatum being in this 21 Santa Monica Pier
or something you know you get explosions
you get hot babes in bikinis [ __ ] yeah
and yeah uh you know buff guys it's
everything you want from Baywatch
I guess this is the time is
entertainment edits most right now yeah
this yeah exactly this is the epitome of
right now entertainment yeah hey I'm
still enjoying it when it's fun so this
looks like fun
and I know uh Priyanka Chopra that's a
big thing I think it's a surname she's
an Indian actress that a lot of Indian
fans are very excited for she's gonna be
in a Hollywood film that's cool she's
the treatment I think she had like a
moment in the trailer did you like one
scene but yeah I mean this looks simple
no need to go into a crazy detail dream
about it
and you know like I needed crazy predict
plus I'm just hoping that I laughs and
then I had there's some that's fun and
I'm sure this will be a really fun time
and if it does well the box-office
expect a franchise there you go
Hollywood I like these people I have my
ticket of comedy I mean the director of
Horrible Bosses also did identity thief
so we don't know if it's gonna be good
cuz Horrible Bosses is hilarious
identity thief was one of the worst
movies I've ever seen well who's the
writer oh and Alexander today I thought
I recognized her since she the chicken
is in [ __ ] San Andreas yeah yeah
Alexander Dario dollar Jack cents
instead of her playing his daughter
maybe he gets the boner in this room
instead oh it would it be creepy and it
would make perfect sense because he
already had the sexiest daughter of all
time and I mean it's from the guy she
wrote Freddy vs. Jason in the Friday the
13th reboot this these are the the right
people to reboot this movie at the you
go the best players on board I know the
rock and Bob Zac Efron it this looks
exactly like what I'd want it to be a
total blast and that looks like fun I
will be there I will definitely be
checking this film out if you're new to
this channel you can subscribe today
call yourself a reject yeah jon is
reasons Jerry on Twitter and Instagram
is a social media manager of Facebook
sites a bloom house and the real rejects
and Jon I want to give a shout out to
someone who mentioned you someone I
mentioned me some girl who knows her
roles only mention Jon girls never
mentioned it that's not only guys who
are like I love you grow you're so cool
but girls are never never never
her name is Carmen Torres uncle Jon I
really like you aren't you and every
oh that he makes you guys should make
every video together that's so sweet
Carmen Torres if you're not underage as
I can't tell John is available jon is
available if you're not underage it's my
only standard it's only standards the
only thing I'm about weight doesn't
matter to him ethnicity doesn't matter
personality you could be dull or the
life of the party John is desperate
desperate John that's what we call them
right that's exactly true